ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
let's play roller coaster tycoon I've
been gone for a bit bonum it's time to
work on leaf you lake and these paths
are oh I try to use as why can't I I
mean you're only allowed to actually use
the arrow keys to move around here which
is quite unfortunate but it's time to
remove these path thingies because
guests are gonna be lost and stuff you
don't want that so this is a extremely
big map but you've got this big portion
of the map which doesn't look all that
interesting really I usually fill this
thing up with have one big roller
coaster that's not really made to make
profit but just to get that big thing
out there but today I think I'm just
going to open the park and build what we
need to build because I'm quiet in here
we need a carousel yeah this should be
good
I'm gonna make this more spread out then
I usually make this Park usually I try
to cram as many small rides around the
borders of the lake as I can but that
doesn't really seem to be on the most
how to put it realistic way of dealing
with this bike so I'm actually gonna try
to make it look a bit better and of
course that's all start with a nice
bathroom over here somebody actually
commented about the fact that I didn't
use any um what do you call those things
again campaigns which I totally forgot
about these things it's it's quite
stupid really I always used to use them
but for some reason I just forgot about
their existence and I should probably
use them as soon as my Park is large
enough for that that is because it
doesn't I think but I'm not sure but
this is my experience that it doesn't
really work too well if you're if you've
still got a yeah very small Park it only
really works when you have a park that's
kind of all the rides are running less
well guests then their maximum capacity
and that's where you can actually try
and use some of those campaigns to get
some more guests in your park we can
only start out with some terrible rides
we should look at the research get rid
of those things don't want that I don't
think I need any stalls either
I do I definitely do I'm gonna research
that too and I'm not too big of a fan of
these rides and nobody really cares
about a ferris wheel but I'm just gonna
place one near the entrance why not yeah
just like that
and oh wait I forgot the exit well
that's done
do I need to name these things yeah I'll
probably do these are I don't know why
this is just a name that uh no no of
course it needs to be plural
it's a carousel after all and this one
is going to be I have no idea we've
already used the Bueller wheel nothing
else to do I suppose hmm this is gonna
be Don McLean's as a ride because he's
cool however of course he doesn't need
an entrance why am i using these yellow
cue lines they're not even that nice
might why some blue ones actually that's
not that nice either you know what I'm
gonna use the yellow ones after all okay
nobody wants to enter that however we
can raise the price to 110 that's
phenomenal well we'll do that and this
is one is just going to take one
rotation because otherwise everybody's
gonna complain and wait oh of course
130 no good enough but you know it's
time to add something exciting
obviously it's time for a good old
roller coaster and the only things that
we got these two things which are not my
favorite things but I suppose this to
your mini roller coaster is always nice
to build so I'll just start off with
that a nice modest not too expensive but
still somewhat thrilling right to start
off with and can i buy this line over
there I should yeah I can I'll just buy
land if I need to
really I won't save up too much of my
money don't want to do any of that I'm
long station is a handy but I'd rather
have a good lift here as well I don't
know what it is when it comes to the
look of this ride it's probably just my
nostalgia but I just like the look of
this ride just the track in the I can't
even explain it it just looks so cute
and I want to I went to hug it I don't
know it's probably my childhood though
that doesn't look good that does not
look good we could do this but that's an
element that looks great from three
perspectives and terrible from one
perspective as you can see it looks good
from over here looks good from here
looks good from here but when you rotate
the camera like that it just looks
terrible so don't quite want to do that
well I could do that hmm and then just
kind of zigzag my way around that I
suppose I know what that looks like
doesn't look too good though I'd almost
say it look no that doesn't look good
either hmm I'm not a fan of diagonals in
this game because obviously they look
good from one angle I mean two angles
but terrible from the other two so I
don't know why it just kind of looks
awkward like this and I want to get that
nice little thing where you have that
curve and then you go down like that
again there's no way I can do that over
here well I'll just try to do it like
that mm-hmm
this track is pretty high isn't it
it could even be one square lower I'm
gonna make it a little shorter that's a
bit better now I'm still stuck over here
though so don't really know what to do
there hmm I could do something funky
like that but I'd rather have a nice and
twisty layout so definitely not anything
like that I'd say that perhaps my best
option is just to do this plus it looks
really good from over here I do have to
say that hmm but then again it's
probably also very slow at this point
what are you doing go away damn it
what is this what no we don't I go away
come on what are you doing doesn't even
want to let me click on it Wow
oh there we go
never never again okay thank you
back to the game um I still don't know
what to do with this thing hmm no that's
too painful mm-hmm I just don't know
what to do with this
and I don't think something like that
would work out how about the footpath in
the way I've completely stuck already I
feel like as soon as I get this thing
over with
I can actually come up with the rest of
the right easily but it just doesn't
want to work now does it
that's a definite no should I just go
for this instead I suppose I should okay
I'm just going to try this and I'm
getting I don't know I'm still stuck
over there go back yes that is sexy land
not owned by the park I don't care um
it's very slow at that point though but
oh it just looks so good
what if I uh make that a small curve
then it should work and nope says the
game it doesn't work hmm plus the small
curve looks very awkward you know what
in that case I'm actually gonna I'm
actually gonna try that but I'm gonna
make this thing a bit higher again I
think I do have an idea what to do so
I'm gonna do that same thing except this
time I'm gonna go down one H over here
just to get that slight height
difference and to keep the speed in the
ride and then we can do some shenanigans
with the waterfront over there and then
I would say that this ride is nearly
finished and looking pretty good I say
hmm although then I'm still stuck over
there hmm
but you know that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about that cue really so screw that
thing just make that one smaller there
we go and construction continues on this
thing need 11 well that's a bit high oh
well I don't care and that's a very Sun
ending I'm not sure if I want that
either
hmm what if I try something like this
over there and no no I'm still stuck I'm
definitely still stuck something like
that and then we go down and up again no
well I'm still stuck well nobody needs
those trees just get out of there I need
to see if this works
nope but that's too spread out I don't
want it to be that wide
but we do have those instance things
that go up but that's too high
definitely okay small curve then does
that work I mean it does look a bit
quirky but hmm it could work it really
could but then again that is a bit high
as well might actually make it lower hmm
and then I'm still stuck there the
problem is I don't want it to end that
soon I don't want to go to the station
right away but I do want to add
something over here and it's really hard
to do that especially with the amount of
space that we're giving you and then
there's that annoying path over there
you know I could just go down and then
just go into the station like that that
would definitely work but I feel like
it's too boring
I want more action you know what I'm
just gonna bite oh well there goes my
plan of buying land that was my only
solution what what am I going to do now
hmm okay this one is cool I like that
but I'm still stuck over there what if I
just do something stupid and go up over
there small curve yeah that's and it
should I should be able to do that but
that just looks awkward as well
hmm I'm still not sure what to do and
this wasn't too bad of an idea but that
small curve at the end I mean now that I
think about it hold on I am pretty sure
that I can buy all of that line over
there yes I can okay I'm just gonna buy
a [ __ ] ton of land over here I don't
care anymore okay over though I'm just
gonna remove all of those trees and I'm
gonna buy enough land over here just to
make a small little helix ish kind of
thing thankfully we can actually buy all
of the land over here without having
small spots that we can't buy and I
don't think the guests are too afraid of
those tight corners so I suppose I don't
give a [ __ ]
we should however add some brakes over
here so some brakes and into the station
hmm I do like that though it might still
be a bit too small I can always change
that I do want to see if I can actually
use this and otherwise I'm just gonna
buy more land but buying land is quite
expensive especially in this part
because you're of course given plenty of
land to work with what can I do with
this oh well 15 you should do I like
smaller trains they just look better so
I want to try it with this and otherwise
I'm gonna just buy two more squares over
here
okay let's see what the speed is and I
don't know what I should do with the
collars though I mean it looks cool like
this but it is the standard collars so
not too sure if I actually want to use
that oh wait I don't have any mechanics
Wow that's done yeah it's definitely too
fast at the end hold on I'm gonna buy
more land I'm just gonna do it
screw it like that and like that and
that should do come on mate let me edit
that I have barely any money left
already that's very nice now I should
actually be able to get over there with
a medium curve which is a lot more
comfortable but then again I might
actually try something else as well hmm
I don't think that would be possible
really but I could give it a shot now
that looks very awkward let's say that's
definitely you know although you know
this might just work although that's too
low okay hold on let me try it like that
now that's still an awkward construction
isn't it yep it is
okay I'm gonna not do that I'm just
gonna do it like this and I'm gonna bank
that curve of course and oh we can
actually go down over there as well
in that case I'm just gonna do that
is it gonna add a helix and oh wait hold
on
you can add a helix over there into the
breaks right into the breaks and a huge
station okay this is gonna be perfect
Oh God wait wait wait oh wait this
breaks over there whoops and station and
yes also I'm gonna move the station
because using all of the space we have
and another cue like that
and that should look good how many
trains can I have for trains of five
cards should do really I think I can
actually get three of ten oh just to
attend well then this I suppose nice and
in terms of speed it should also be
really good so I think I'm happy with
this ride it's not the best write that
I've ever placed in this position but I
do like it it's good enough it gets the
job done I suppose and I still need to
play some rides and stuff over here and
some decorations so it should definitely
be it should definitely be good question
is what if what am I going to name this
thing hmm
well the speed seems to be really good
doesn't kill anyone and into the brakes
and those are some killer brakes Rob
Alfie would not approve and so I
wouldn't either really but at least it's
safe so we won't get straight allies
complaining in the comment section so I
suppose it gets the job done and in
terms of color scheme I still just oh
wait
that doesn't even look all that bad okay
that looks me but this would actually
look decent wait get that blue-collar
ill are too blue there is actually such
a thing as too blue I did not expect it
to exist but it is there and what could
this be better no that's a very awkward
color I think this should be good
I'm gonna make these things black or
something I do like that I actually do
like that I'm not I'm still not too
happy about the supports either the
supports or the crossbars is something
that I'm not too happy about yeah this
definitely doesn't work and this
probably won't work either no too much
of that awkward stuff going on
I suppose this is okay but it's not
really what I want and nobody nobody
likes great so breaking oh [ __ ] off hmm
know what I'm gonna make it like this
and I'm gonna open it because I need
profit because I'm losing money I think
oh and that's terrible and right it
wasn't the right construction it was oh
where was the line purchase nevermind
I'm probably still making profit as long
as I don't build anything however I need
to make more profit obviously because I
need to rights this is going to be
called I don't know I should not cut try
and come up with terrible names because
frankly I'm terrible with that maybe
another ill storm reference I don't know
this is going to be shipwrecked you know
you do need to you need you do need to
use some names they're kind of you know
cool like that and getting shipwrecked
is pretty cool so I'm and we're gonna
add a exclamation point to that all of
this makes it so much more look they're
already queuing for it that's just
because that one exclamation point I
tell you and how much is this going to
cost for 40 you know that's a ridiculous
amount of money for just one coaster
ride but oh well Who am I to complain I
mean these people are willing to pay
that
ah look at them go that's where the
peeps are so cute in this game
so that was shipwrecks and that was our
a small Pike so far which is not looking
too shabby of course there's not too
much in it and in the next episode I'll
be able to actually do some scenery
stuff so see you then